for all the talk about Russian meddling
in the 2016 presidential election there
are many people who are not aware that
Russia is accused right now I'm talking
about June 2018 of meddling in the 2018
midterm election and this has not been
getting a lot of attention Robert Mulder
put out a statement saying that Russian
intelligence as we speak is engaged in
quote interference operations related to
the upcoming 2018 midterm election and
the most pressing one of course is the
possibility of Republicans losing
control of the house and or Senate
so in general we should be opposed to
foreign meddling in elections we have a
particularly sort of precarious and
high-stakes midterm coming up and if you
remember those 13 indictments of Russian
nationals from February for election
meddling prosecutors who have been
working on those cases have found
evidence of more people and more
companies that are actively meddling in
the upcoming election right now and
there are individuals who have not as
have yet been charged with anything as
part of the current investigation that
the government believes are engaging as
we speak how many times do I have to say
right now as we speak in the same type
of interference for which 13 people have
already been indicted and meanwhile you
won't be shocked to hear that the Trump
administration is doing nothing to stop
this funds that have been allocated to
stop Russian meddling remain unused no
public statements from the Trump
administration that ending this meddling
and interference is a priority and this
is very visible even on our own
platforms Pat spends a lot of time on
the internet doing what who knows but
he's on the Internet
you notice the comments that are
appearing on our YouTube channel you
don't have to spend a lot of time
looking at our YouTube channel to
realize what's going on and there's
nothing special about our channel right
it's just that these campaigns are so
massive and highly effective and
well-funded disinformation campaigns
that they're targeting anybody who's
doing any kind of critical reporting
about what's taking place with Russia
and for people
who are interested I've been observing
this for a while on our channel and one
of the tactics online is the trolls
Russian - a story we do that might be
critical of Russia in some way or even
critical of Trump
they math down vote the real organic
comments from actual viewers and then
they start having conversations with
each other and up voting them and mass
to make those seem like the most popular
and interesting conversations and a lot
of times you'll see phrases like I don't
like Trump either but that's like a
signal that you've got a troll situation
happening on your channel another one is
the use of memes so a lot of memes there
are some character types that you see
there's also the people who pose as
moderate Democrats who claim that they
don't want the left taken over by
extremist leftist that's another common
thread that they use you can see this
happening in real time every day on our
channel yeah and some people will retort
and say David you know I dislike all
your videos and I comment negative
comments and all your videos and I'm not
a Russian but I'm not a Russian
operative so what do you have to say to
them that's exactly what they want you
to be saying which is the fact that some
people in some real people do exist with
these positions that is exactly what
they hide behind and what's really
important to understand is there's
nothing unique about Russia doing this
or about other countries doing this to
the US right many countries use
disinformation campaigns to meddle in
elections Russia does it not just to the
United States they do it to other
countries as well
what's unique right now is that we have
an administration that's in the White
House right now that has become sort of
a de facto if not a willing ally at
least an indifferent one and that
indifference from the Trump White House
is what's so dangerous and just to come
full circle with this we've been talking
about how Donald Trump has been
justifying tariffs on Canada by saying
that they're a national security threat
there are Republicans who agree with
Trump that Canada is a national security
threat and that by providing material
for our military vehicles it is
something that we should be very
concerned about and should put tariffs
on them but they somehow don't seem
to think there's any threat whatsoever
from russia when robert muller says hey
everybody they're actively interfering
right now in our elections i don't know
how you square that i think that you
there is no sensible way to say canada
is a national security threat by
providing steel for tanks but russia
continuing to actively metal is not a
security threat like how how do you get
so partisan that you end up thinking
that that makes sense i truly don't
understand i don't know either
a big picture with all this stuff I
guess the silver lining is that there
still is some time right five months
until the next midterm election and once
you closer to an election people start
taking you know election integrity more
seriously right things like voter fraud
and voter suppression and all that stuff
a little bit more seriously so maybe
there's some hope there that was pat
playing his character naive wide-eyed
bushy-tailed Pat where he thinks that
anything is gonna be fixed in the next
five months I wish I could believe that
but there is absolutely no chance in
hell that this gets resolved for the
midterm election